um I guess we'll get started some people
we you know joining us but uh thanks for
coming to bring me mental health data to
doctors my name is Bill Lynch I'm a data
scientist at normal flow where I I work
within the product to you mostly but you
know I touched all aspects of the
business coming from you know a start-up
kind of world and hopefully you know
today I'm going to share some of the
learnings of building data products for
doctors and mental health you know
professionals that you know hopefully
help you be more successful you know in
your in your functions so a little bit
of background real quick on where I work
normal flow is a digital health platform
that basically allows behavioral health
specialists to assess monitor and track
patient mental health so they have an
app with tools like journaling and
guided content that kind of helps them
on their journey towards mental
well-being and for for organizations
specifically our how our platform helps
you know pain management practices
integrate behavioral health into their
care settings and helps them engage more
proactively you know around the patient
mental health I'm like I guess EHRs and
traditional paper based solutions which
tend to silo mental and physical health
so we're trying to you know bridge that
gap what we're gonna cover we're gonna
go over we're going to talk about you
know how we add norm flow think about
data when it comes to the mental health
side of healthcare how to make sure it's
impactful and actionable how we
determine what to work on and you know
anywhere flow and also how I how I get
the organization to think about data
when when making decisions and and kind
of how I empower you know you know the
others that I work with to think about
and have a discussion about their data
alright so kick it off give a little
background in the context around you
know the gravity of the situation where
we're dealing with every day
one in five adults in the United States
behavior hostage order each year and
suicide is the 10th leading cause of
death in the United States so clearly
you know they're soaking there's a need
to provide
we monitor for mental health conditions
such as depression and anxiety but the
challenges to doing so effectively are
plentiful so speak to 67% for instance
of people with behavioral health
disorder they don't get appropriate
treatment so they there's this huge
stigma around mental health they tend to
feel that there's some sort of shame in
going to a therapist whereas you know we
all go to a gym to kind of whip our
bodies into shape you should be able to
go to a therapist to do what your mind
into shape so that's kind of the first
problem we're trying to reduce the
stigma around you know seeing a mental
health professional and then to all
those that do see mental health
professionals the the way they
deliberate currently is infrequent
paper-based measurements and solutions
so it's not only hard to get people to
go to therapy it's hard to make people
stay in therapy and also bring back
anything that's you know remotely
meaningful on their progress because
you're giving them something 30 days
prior and I'm gonna come back with a
complete so it's tough for them to kind
of keep tabs on the progress of middle
of the patient's mental health and then
finally the keynote speaker kind of
touched on this in the prison population
but medical costs are two to three times
more among those with comorbidities
behavioral health conditions and
comorbidities so if I have a bad back
and you guys have bad back if I have
depression I'm gonna be two to three
times more costly in the long run than
then you so there's there's clearly like
I need to understand and improve these
processes and we're doing a good job
finally there's a lot of research out in
the psychology and kind of healthcare
domains that looking at those
relationships between depression and
anxiety and and what you do in your
daily life how you feel in your daily
life and at the same time we're also
advancing every
in digital technology capabilities you
know more people have stable internet
more people are gothic smartphones so
it's easier than ever to kind of have
the digital solution for remote patient
monitoring and and an instant delivery
of you know data trends resources all
that stuff alright so in order to make
our users more efficient and improve
outcomes we kind of offer a variety of
ways to to improve their workflow so as
I mentioned north was an app where for
patients and providers we gather all of
this patient and provider generated data
and essentially allow them their pick of
ways to to understand their data you
know you have the the format choice you
have your your pick up your reporting
and visualizations and so we we
ultimately want to build a product for
them so they can do less while
understanding you know their patient
populations more and improving their
outcomes overall so for instance one of
the things you can do is track whether
or not people are doing doing things
inside of the app you know you can track
and see if people are actually
completing homework that are given to
them if they're completing journals that
were assigned and if not you can kind of
dodge them to do so you can also see how
people are doing longitudinally in terms
of their symptom reduction through their
questionnaires or you can understand and
see over time how mood is changing if
their pain is reducing and if they're
you know they're sleeping better you can
also see and check it through funnels
you know if people are doing things that
are associated with successful outcomes
are they registering are they doing a
certain number of things in the first
month I'll be continuing on this path
towards you know success and then
finally we also offer a way for them to
track their their patient population and
kind of service to them the ones that
are maybe the risk is and they should
you know they should look afterwards and
spend time on the most so the common
thread though for all for all of these
things
is that one which I collaborate with you
know product design and other team
members is that we have to kind of we
have to make it digestible because you
know you can have like an amazing
amazing model or you know awesome data
to end projects they are working out but
there's not a story around it it's no
one's gonna use it and no one's gonna
care about it so you kind of have to
make sure that you have a closer
relationship with our all your
stakeholders you're going to work with
so as a team you guys can you know
collaborate and make sure that your end
user is being successful they've got
wins and one of the one of the most
important metrics and ways we deliver
data is is towards patient outcomes
right at the end of the day behavioral
health specialists want a quick way to
understand how the patients are doing if
they're getting better or worse or who
you know who should they attend to
essentially and so in order to deliver
you know the patient outcomes in a way
that's digestible we go to an algorithm
that stratifies their population and
allows the provider to efficiently
allocate their time and you know
resources on those that that needs to
most and so the way we did it we took in
all this all the data that we have you
know we have question areas on day on on
people we have mobile health data you
know steps Apple health kind of stuff
heart rate all that we have momentary
data a mood sleep pain and then we have
in-app interaction did and with that we
can kind of use all this historical data
to you know present a kind of risk score
for four new examples and so now what
we're doing we have a product that
basically takes clinical policy into a
turn it turns it into an algorithm right
we have a way for doctors to not have to
go to all this disparate data sources in
the myriad of data we we kind of bring
it all together and and give it to them
and like a single summary statistics
statistics so yeah so like they don't
have to obviously take the time and
after
to do it themselves we provide it in a
way that's too easily digestible kind of
insightful that for us means including
the ingredients in the analysis to kind
of build both faith and kind of trust so
like if it's a if it's a cake we're
gonna tell them we're putting in you
know sugar butter whatnot we're not
telling them the quantities that's kind
of too in-depth it might lose them but
we're allowing them to know yeah that
makes sense you know
and we're also including language
expressing how confident we feel about
it so you know in a way where we're kind
of just consolidating and condensing it
all this information so that they don't
really need to do it themselves and
connect the dots themselves so that's
one of the ways and the next one that
pretty excited about what we do it's
it's around natural kind of processing
and on text data so so for us we have
behavioral specialists that have their
patients write in journals and tell them
how they're feeling right they kind of
give them topics to write about and they
come in and you know discuss what the
patient has written in the journals and
then take action on it it kind of
informed their their their care and give
them next steps and so again what we
wanted to do is to automate this process
because it takes a lot of time and
effort to go through and read all these
journals it takes a lot of effort to
analyze all these journals and they just
don't have they don't have they don't
have that you know they're very busy and
so we wanted to build an automated way
for them to do that so what we're doing
is we're kind of we're building an
ecosystem of classical and deep learning
based natural line of processing
techniques so we can you know we
corporate sentiment analysis and
emotional state analysis in order to to
really identify the degree to which a
patient may be suffering and by
detecting that you know the intensity of
their suicidal ideations or or there you
know self-harm thoughts we can reduce
the time spent for a provider
on on reading the journals and analyzing
the journals and increasing the
efficiency for them so they can go and
practically average you know their their
patient and get to them quickly and
efficiently you know we want to want to
be able to say there might be something
harmful on this you should take a look
at it
mrs. úrsula and from a data perspective
again it's all about bringing in those
those disparate data sources and using
them to provide insight and and build
like you know a more complete profile of
the patient that otherwise would would
take too much time and effort for for
the providers to do themselves for Emma
from our perspective that's kind of what
it's all about outcomes and engagement
are what submission of you know Norfolk
kind of is obviously how to retain
customers and the traditional KPIs are
important to the bottom line I work with
sales customer success you know c-level
exact but you know our mission is to
help others feel better and whether
that's through the provider or patient
themselves it doesn't matter you know we
just need to be able to to deliver that
and digestible way so our so our
patients can get better and there they
can see improved outcomes but how do we
how do I know where to start a
data-driven process it's kind of obvious
but you gotta start the question and I
can come to a variety of ways you might
have you know your CDO ask how can we my
CEO would ask how can i how can we help
make dr. phibes easier or my head of
product money how can you know how can
usually get a personalized experience
how can we make it how can we make it
stickier is there something that you
know a North Star kind of metric where
they do X number of things and they they
see improved results a commitment or are
they or they stay how can we how can we
get that everyone get that down and it's
also kind of at this stage a place where
you get to kind of tell them what they
can do a lot of times it's not fully
formed or it's a great idea but we're
not ready to do that yet so this is the
step where you can say you know it's
this is a great idea but
we were out there and it's also a place
to understand where what their pain
points are you know what they what they
need help with
and also you gotta leverage user stories
and we're close to it it's super
important to understand your users
whether that's internal or external you
know understand their pain points what
they like to do what they don't like to
do what they want to do but can't do so
you rip out your real opportunity to to
provide value to your internal users to
get them you know to come back and to
get them to - towards their journey
towards mental you know improved mental
health but you can also help your help
your you know internal stakeholders by
understanding how they think about
things what were the matters to them you
can kind of help guide them and on their
and reach their their goals because
that's kind of that's the goal in a way
of like what you know what I do I got to
figure out how I analytics person can
help you be more successful and reach
your goals whether that's through the
patient or you know or internally my
stakeholders for customer success it
might be you know around retention or
customer satisfaction maybe if you ask
for product you know that might be
around engagement and stickiness and
then for for c-level company goals or
even patience you know it's helping
helping them out helping those patients
see symptom reduction while using your
flow and while you're asking the doing
those two the first two things you're
gonna want to ask all the questions
essentially set clear goals because a
lot of times in my experience
stakeholders might say one thing but
they they mean another so there's just a
waste of time for you and then if you do
something that's not fully fleshed out
and you bring it back and they're like
oh this is great um but I want you to do
a completely dry so it's not really
helpful for any party involvement and
the sooner you can really get to the why
and the more successful you'll be in
starting a project
and we'll be successful and then FP
accepted clear goals you gotta you gotta
set obviously clear expectations on end
result and timeline especially in a
data-driven project which is different
than you know an engineering project
whether it's South Carroll carrot
doesn't matter we we as data people we
have tough kind of poorly defined
problems that don't that aren't easy to
partition in terms of like tasks like
like engineer you know they have these
nice time box like clearly defined
problems and we we don't have that
luxury and so you need to explain that I
need you to set expectations based on
that and let's go about your timeline
for instance you know there are a bunch
of a bunch of considerations whether
it's the complexity of the data whether
it is if we're building it for product
how it's going to interact integrate you
know and then how long it might take to
to gather in and get that information
and store that information it could take
a while it's very open-ended but for
instance I guess well I was working well
I was working on the severity score that
you saw we had all that information
gathered in our system so it was super
easy I didn't have to go anywhere to go
out and get that data but for the
journaling aspect of our product you
know I needed to to spend time making
sure that we had a labelled data set
that was specific to our problem there's
a ton of data sets out there that you
can use on sense man or you know that
use like social media and whatnot but or
different core purposes but at corporate
but we needed it specifically for our
problem of understanding patient you
know suicidal self-harm kind of emotions
and so setting expectations is like is
super is key I know it's tough though to
estimate one of the one of the things
that that kind of helps me is I think
about it in three ways right I think
about how long I like it to take given
the rest of my workload how long I
actually think it's going to take given
what we know the complexity the set up
the infrastructure you know the data
we have so on and so forth and then how
long I think it's gonna actually take
given meetings giving like these ad hoc
things that always come up and from
there I'm usually able to to give a
pretty clear estimate and also end
result of what it's going to be but as
long as you communicate openly and often
and you're kind of transparent you're
setting these expectations you're gonna
be in a much better place to succeed
because they'll know you know they'll
know not to expect a finished product
they might they might have an iteration
of it that you need to discuss and kind
of like suss out a little more and when
it finally I guess comes to actually
doing it for instance one of the things
it was kind of my template I guess if
it's for a product or customer success I
always have I always open up with a
white board accession you know we have
we have a brainstorm where we define the
problem we want to solve we figure out
the business value we design those KPIs
and we identify the challenges some of
the challenges for instance you know
might be about business definitions or
the definitions they might be kind of
vague so you need to iron out and make
sure you know sort of single source of
truth on that
where else you might run into problems
later on and then also there could be
challenges with data the data might not
be there yet
it might be to be added or you know
there might be some bugs in the data
it's like I can get you a bunch of
dinner but there's gonna be two weeks
missing when we you know push something
that should have been pushing there's
bug in it so it's kind of at this point
understanding where we're at what the
problem is that you're gonna eventually
got into and then usually the that's
where I go off I start gathering the
data understanding it and exploring it
the key here though is to iterate
iterate often you know alpha has to tell
authors what they say but that's kind of
what I do I visualize and it's back to
haterade and then you know rinse and
repeat and that's kind of the key the
key to success for me is at this point
because it count for me stay efficient
it helps me keep that line of
communication open and it also helps me
not fall into a rabbit hole which is
super fun I love doing it and it's like
it ends up you know
not really being so great on the bottom
line so that's why doing keeping keeping
things in this cadence of communication
like quick it allows you to kind of
write that in and then finally you know
say I go in and I I gather that I I
understand and I'm back I'm ready to to
talk with the the State Quarter it
doesn't what I bring back doesn't have
to be beautiful actually no it doesn't
be the horse it doesn't have to be like
complex I guess it might just be a
simple Python graph or you know math lab
that graph or I might run by my stick or
through a ipython notebook depending on
what the problem is I might spin out
like a web app but it is really all
dependent on how easily you know I could
communicate my results from there and I
go back like I said rinse and repeat or
we're making a decision
can we go forward from there I mean
bringing out a bar deed to first
engineering to kind of make sure we
could productize it to sync up on house
what it's going to look like for it for
a for a data product at home speaking
with customer success it might be just
putting it on you know a dashboard
something like that but for product it's
I'm bringing it to engineering to kind
of sync up and then design to make it
beautiful I think all my colors and
stuff and seems to look great but I
forget to design it they're like yeah
this is this s is got yeah we got we're
gonna redo all of this and then if
they're never meet some marketing
customer success where they can kind of
focus in on you know the message that
we're going to deliver externally as
well as internally how we're gonna teach
our users and then you know how we're
gonna actually get feedback as early as
possible so that's kind of key to the
whole data driven project is it's kind
of the in attempt are making sure it's a
collaborative effort effort because
having those having those people
involved in and having a data centric
stakeholder and you know a solid data
culture where people kind of get what
you're talking about is obviously it
makes things easier when you're trying
- to go on a data-driven project but how
do you I guess where to start how do you
do that
for us and I think for everybody my my
top priority is just to make sure I
document everything it's going to be the
key business definitions it's gonna be
table structures and and you know
unclear column names and whatnot because
I don't want I want to be the lines so
that I don't get sales for instance
coming to me and saying like this number
looks wrong and it's because they go
they're going by the different
definition and so you end up when it
happens like you end up spending time
talking about the filters you apply down
there to the data source that you got
and not actually really answering the
question so the sooner you can provide a
place for a single source of truth for
those things the easier like your life
will be and also the kind of more
data-driven and data center you know
your ear your company's going to be that
being said I know it's not it's not easy
or fun to to document but you just got
to start somewhere and that kind of
it'll grow over time gonna do it at your
own pace but just just start it's gonna
eventually grow out and then once it
starts growing out and and you you know
you have a team if you can incorporate
it into a nice handbook where you know
you have your your outline your how to's
your outline your your processes your
style guides you know might be a place
for the for the analytics tracking and
then you can also have a spot for how
people can find you you don't when they
have a data question you can give them a
place to find all the answers because
you don't want that scenario to happen
where you you you're in a company where
only a few people know where all the
data or like the data lives right so you
want to be able to to provide that
documentation so that you know that they
do if the documentation is there it
lives there they're gonna find it so
they can they can start finding these
answers you know on their own number two
is to make noise so that's kind of
it's key you gotta you gotta make
yourself easy for people to find and
then hard for people to ignore for us
I have us we have a slack data channel
we're up throwing my thoughts out there
on blog posts people will ask me
questions before we might turn it into a
ticket or be left like that open forum
that of a discussion place and then
every couple weeks I have a data science
roundup where you know I'll go over all
the cool things should make sure that
the visibility is there about what we're
doing and so it doesn't get lost in you
know the you know the shuffle because
maybe sure you know you're your
president in the organization it helps
you be more efficient but in the long
run but it also will help them you know
understand how you're thinking about
start to understand how to think about
about data one of the things that has
helped me as I kind of said before is
connecting with your stakeholder so
going out and building rapport for my my
company that's like everybody I guess so
I just I talk with everybody might not
be like that in the near future where
you know you'll be focused on certain
stakeholders you might not be able to to
take it everybody's name okay get
everybody's deep understanding on how
they think but when you can you should
because it helps you understand their
problem and how they think about what
you know the metrics one more what
number might be important to them or
what they're actually thinking about you
know the next time around it's just just
gets easier and easier and then one of
the other things that the final things
that has helped me make noise and kind
of be present in the organization is to
do some user acceptance testing with
with their developers on data components
so it's it's tough because building for
an application is way different than
building for data so they didn't
necessarily know the data consideration
so you have to be that fly in the air
make sure that they know how the
companies are using the data how I'm
using data just to make sure you know
they think I I drill it in until they
get it right
and then three embracing it yes
mentality so that's a key that's a key
value we have at north loan and it
definitely like trickles down
specifically to the data science you
know what we do what we do is tough and
there isn't always like an open a clear
answer but there is always an answer you
just have to dig deeper and have that
grit kind of like keep going and
persevere yet they ask the right
questions
but I guess awesome to clarify you don't
want to say yes to everything though
you're gonna like you're gonna you're
you're gonna regret it it started it was
you're going down you know you'll end up
losing spreading yourself too thin right
in the annual you'll lose that time
management skill you lose that kind of
in-depth understanding the questions and
the things that there are you know
coming coming to you for I guess at a at
a certain point time it is good to kind
of jumpstart but you're gonna grow and
that's gonna set an awful president
because you're not gonna be able to do
that as you grow you don't be able to
say yes to everything and so that goes
with my next point now teach people to
fish so they're never going to learn to
do it themselves if you keep doing it
for them so one of the biggest
challenges I find is that it's not hard
for me to create the analysis or the
dashboard or the report it's kind of
getting them to learn about it and kind
of spend time actually understanding it
most people at North flow and your
companies want answers from data and
most people ignore flow and your
companies they're capable of finding the
answers from the data given the right
tool so you kind of have to just connect
the two one of the things that I've been
doing depending on your your comedy
scale you'll find mixed results I guess
your mileage may vary but I've taught
others basic sequel those that are kind
of the data centric people that could
that could use use those use that
connection I teach them basically
so you basically will come in commands
how how are our database works and the
key relationships that they may they may
work with and need to know and
how to find basically their own answers
in the in the business dolphin tool when
our you know guy drop GUI doesn't do it
enough I mean I still get complicated
queries they don't do those but they're
often running going pulling from data
more more and more each day and it's
great because it it's like instead of
them coming saying hey Villa like do
this for me it's hey Bill I've done this
can you review it so it's not last mile
then again now and I'll take that all
day everybody every day you know it
helps that problem where you you feel
like most people will come to you like
they're at you know a cafeteria and
they're waiting for like this data food
that you're dishing out this is like one
little glad that people want to answer
so when you teach people to fish it
helps kind of break down that line and
they can do things on their own and one
of the last few steps here against is
relying on your roadmap making sure you
are setting expectations and your your
do you're transparent about it and open
about it because it's key to not only a
successful career or organizational
development but it's key to learn how
you're gonna be pull in a thousand
different ways than you need to be able
to balance you know those short-term
continual projects with the long-term
projects and then also you want
obviously several of your data as soon
as possible in my opinion the earlier
you do it the more questions we'll be
able to answer you know the more
relationships you'll be able to explore
and the picture of things such as you
know user journeys will just be more
complete and you'll be able to to get
those those insights more quickly and
finally communicate openly and often so
this also allows for organizational
alignment
it allows for your transparency and
accountability in a step because it
establishes you know a cadence and so
when it establishes the cadence it
allows you to kind of make sure you're
working on the things that end up
mattering the most to kind of wrap it I
guess wrap it all back together the
overall goal for me of building a
data-driven culture is to be able to to
drive change it's it's requiring
empowering
there's to have a discussion about their
data it's about spreading day throughout
an organization so they've kind of start
to answer questions themselves and it's
about having a well we're well aligned
organizational court that goes you know
beyond like the hey I like data science
buddy checkbox that they're doing you
know it's it's actually having a clear
vision of what that data during future
hall isn't with everybody in the
organization top-to-bottom working
together to achieve it and it is also to
make sure you are flexible I guess in
the long term and specific in the short
term so you gonna rely on when you're
your roadmap for line make sure you're
adaptable and flexible and I know like
there there's I'm sure a ton of other
bullets that we could we could add to
here and there's not a you know I
haven't covered everything but yeah I
hope you guys learned something in here
that you know you succeed in your career
so yeah so how do we kind of how we
start building that that trove of data
that we have the patience it's kind of
an intersection between data and
products really we we ask well yeah we
have them sign up and through the
through the mobile app process you know
you asked for it for the ability to get
into the health data for instance or if
they don't there we also send in push
notifications at different moments or
like we gamify things so they can get
you know incentives to stand to keep
building going these like building these
like streets that that will allow them
to get
through these strategic funnels that you
know laughter for those successful
outcomes so we so it's a lot of it is
built into the to the products we hook
up with the with EHRs as well so we can
get information passed from there but
but for us it's about initially when
they get on board and they signed out
from their providers their provider has
information of them already but then we
ask them for other information you know
as it goes along
and within you know a nice a nice mole
what kind of experience it's not
successfully completing suicide it is
having suicidal ideation so that's
suddenly different there is a part of a
clinically validated assessment that
that is given for depression and anxiety
oh and you can start to understand
through one of those quacks - a few of
the questions but one of them asks about
suicidal ideation and so from there we
we know that they have this or didn't
have it for instance and then also we
have our a kind of set of experts to
kind of come in and help build this
model with us so we know that this is
what they care about they want to work
they want to work towards putting into
this one piece so they don't have to
think about it
as much they just know that they can
come into you know about through review
and and have that and then and then yeah
we test it with them we make sure that
these behavior health specialists and
other experts are are on board and it
sits in the right direction
mm-hmm I see we're doing that was that
something where you would train people
to do it or did you rely solely on the
behavioral health guys yeah we relied on
the experts to do it oh you could yeah
we were thinking of the different ways
like jerking it out and just having like
a bunch of people do it but yeah we work
with a lot of sensitive data and so you
can't have you can't have that and so
whenever possible we have different
connections different like you know our
network set up and we kind of lean on
them to to you know to help us out and
help give those those scores or like
yeah give their their evaluations yeah
yeah yeah whose yeah it's pretty neat
they can all go in and kind of start
annotating it you know on their own they
don't have to be an office or whatever
so it was nice it made it very made it
much much quicker for sure yes
yeah we're actually kind of getting more
about that now we we offer
we're not diagnosing for length
that's right off the bat where we're
making sure we're seeing we're giving
them and we're suggestions essentially
that this you know maybe a you know a
journal that has self-harm in it
one of the things that one of the
challenges that we we have is
unfortunately providers sometimes don't
want to know that stuff to be honest it
creates a liability for them and then
it's kind of I don't know what it is
what it is but how it's one of the one
of the ways that we do that we kind of
bake in extra security to make sure you
know if they want to see it they they
can if they don't they don't have to it
but the patient wants to share the
information they can if the patient
doesn't they don't have to it's it's
actually interesting because get two you
get two sides of the spectrum you get
one set of patients that are all about
writing in journals and wanting their
providers to see what you have what they
have and kind of getting that feedback
from if they're not getting feedback
from the provider they don't like think
it's important and then the other side
of it they want it to be like a journal
that's in you know their home in a
drawer they don't want their different
you know about it so we kind of have to
again understand you know the users and
kind of web what they wanted what they
don't want to try to try to break down
behind tell them you know that this is
this is a will we over all useful to the
how do we actually I guess one of the
things that helps is uh where we don't
have to go through FDA regulations or
decision support also it as a
designation so we don't have to wait for
somebody to make the call that we're
allowed to you know keep iterating one
of that's one of the reasons why we
didn't want to go down to that warehouse
because it's so narrow it takes a really
long time to get things done we wanted
to be able to to kind of fly like a you
know startup that that needs to be able
to to change as your business changes
you know we didn't want to be we don't
didn't want to be pivoting or making did
like fundamental business changes that
we couldn't have that team to to have
that flexibility to iterate so we we
don't actually have to to really slow
down for fergie air or those guns any
other all right cool thanks guys